- Oh boy.
Something I don't need after
that Apple event is caffeine,
but I'm gonna drink it anyway.
The Apple spring loaded event just ended.
I'm not going to lie,
I'm pretty hyped.
First of all,
I feel like this is an event
that we've been waiting for
and a lot of stuff was announced,
but let's just get into it.
I want to cover a lot of
stuff very, very quickly.
One of the first things
that they did announce was
that they have a new
Apple card family plan
so that you'll be able
to add other people,
spouses, family members,
to your Apple credit card
so that they'll also be able
to start building their credit.
There's a new layout for
podcasts, which is very exciting,
'cause my sister and I have a podcast.
If you want to check it out,
I'll put a link in the description.
It's called Same Brain.
Check it out if you haven't already.
It's really cool.
They have some new recommendations.
They also have a new subscription plan
which will give you added benefits.
We also have a new color of the iPhone 12
and the iPhone 12 mini.
It's this beautiful
purple color for spring.
I'm a huge fan of the color purple,
so I'm really excited about this.
Now, moving on to air tags.
This is something that I
feel like has been rumored
for a very, very, very,
very, very, very long time.
For years, I feel like
this is something that we
thought was going to be released
at every single Apple event
and it hasn't.
But today is the day.
So using the find my network
which I feel like I'm never just,
I don't know about the whole
name of find my, it's weird.
But it also works
because it is exactly what you're doing.
You're trying to find your whatever.
Find your iPhone, find your friends
and now find your items.
They're actually really cute
and I think one of the things
that is kind of unique is
you're able to customize
them with emojis or text.
You better believe I will
be customizing the heck
out of my air tags.
I'll be putting these
on absolutely everything
because I feel like I
can't ever find anything.
Like I would probably lose my body
if it was not attached to myself.
So this will work with any U1 device
like the iPhone 12
and it uses precision finding
to guide you to the item.
It's going to be really
funny to see me walk
around this house, trying to find items.
I'm thinking that we
should have an air tag
Easter egg hunt.
Get ready for it.
It's happening.
And the price is actually not too bad.
So for $29, you'll get one.
And for a pack of four they are $99.
Orders will start Friday
and they're going to be
available on April 30th,
which is so soon.
They also show these
Hermés leather accessories,
which are actually really beautiful.
I don't think they set a price on those
because usually Hermés stuff is,
it's a little pricey.
This is kind of exciting.
There's a big update to Apple TV 4k.
It has all new A12 bionic chip.
And you can now play HDR
and high frame rate content
which is really exciting
because the new iPhone
obviously shoots HDR
and HDR 60 frames a second.
So now with this Apple TV 4k,
you'll be able to take
full advantage of that.
They also said
that there is an enhancement
update for airplay.
So that will also be able to support
those higher frame rates.
Which is something that I feel
like I was kind of struggling with.
I sometimes feel like
airplay is just not quite
there when you're streaming
the content from your phone.
So hopefully this update will
help alleviate a lot of that.
This other thing that
was pretty awesome is
color balancing your TV with your iPhone.
And the Apple TV will use light sensors
in your phone that will
compare your TV to standards
and automatically adjust the output.
I think it's cool
that this is something that's
kind of coming to consumers
because when we were watching
his keynote, Tyler was like
I spent like $250 on a
monitor calibration tool.
And now this is something
that everyone could just
do right here at home.
Just be like,
hmm, calibrated.
We're done.
Another thing that I was just, like shook,
they finally freaking
updated the Apple TV remote.
I'm going to be putting a find my air tag
on this Apple TV remote
because for the life of me, I still can't,
I don't know where any of the remotes are.
Where do they go?
They just like disappear,
but they did completely
redesign this remote.
It's now an all one piece aluminum design
with a brand new click pad.
There's a Siri button on the side.
You can use a circular
gesture for job control.
It's all touch based
and you can order the remote separately.
The Apple TV 4k is starting
at $179 for the 32 gig version
and $199 for the 64 gig version.
All right.
So this is where the hype train took off.
When they announced the new iMacs.
So these have been rumored.
So this is really not
like a huge surprise that
they announced an M1 iMac
but they didn't just announce one.
They announced seven different colors.
It's 50% smaller, 11.5
millimeters thin, 24 inch,
11.3 million pixel display.
It also has an upgraded camera,
microphone and speakers.
The front facing FaceTime
HD camera is now 10 ADP
with a larger sensor and
image signal processing.
So what this is doing is
it's basically using AI
to try to improve your image.
I'm also very excited about
this upgraded microphone
because it will definitely
cancel out any other sounds
in the house.
So it's a beam forming microphone
that's basically focusing on you.
And they said that this is
the best mic system ever
in a Mac.
So if they say it, it's gotta be true.
85% faster graphics than
the previous 21 inch max.
50% faster graphics, three
X faster machine processing,
four USB-C ports and
this new power connector.
It just magnetically attaches
to the iMac in the back.
Then it has this braided cable
that will then go to your power brick,
which will nicely sit on the ground.
But what's cool about
this is it actually has
an ethernet port.
So if you want to plug in ethernet,
you don't have to actually
plug it into your Mac.
You can plug it into this brick.
And because of that
little MagSafe connector
that's transferring the
data directly to your iMac.
So I'm very excited about this.
So obviously the highlight of all
of this is these are now M1 powered.
And with this M1 chip,
this is giving the
ability to basically scale
down the logic boards and make
everything so much smaller
because of the system
on a chip technology.
Everything is now much
more powerful and smaller
and compact and way more energy efficient.
Okay. So obviously there's new colors.
And with these new
colors, my first thought
while I was looking at these, I was like
but I want my keyboard to match,
Oh I want my mouse to match,
Oh, I want my track pad to match.
So there's three
variations of the keyboard
and they obviously come
in all of the colors.
The magic keyboard now
has keys for spotlight,
dictation, do not disturb, and emoji.
And for the first time touch ID.
It's cool because it does
come in the smaller version.
They also have one with
the extended keyboard
with the number pad.
I'm a huge number pad fan.
So I will definitely be
getting the number pad version.
I also like that there's a lock
button now on the keyboard.
So if you want to quickly
lock your computer
you can just be like, lock done.
This is me locking my computer.
That's also me unlocking my
computer with my fingerprint.
I love that they have the mouse
and the track pads to match.
Mouse, mice, meese, moose, mmm.
The colors match and the pink iMac,
it might have my name on it.
I don't know if you can
do engraving in this,
but if you could it would
already come with my name on it,
for sure.
So I'm on the, by the only
24 inch iMac, it looks
like there's three variations
that you can purchase.
So the lowest version is the
eight core and the seven core
and this does not have two USB three ports
or the gigabit ethernet.
So that's starting at $1299
and that only comes in four colors,
the blue, green, pink, and the silver.
And the other two models are
the eight core CPU and GPU.
And at $1499, that's
your 256 gigs of storage
and then 512 is starting at $1699.
And these have all of the colors.
The blue, green, pink, silver,
yellow, orange, and purple.
It's interesting though
because they didn't do
like a space gray version.
So I feel like they kind
of want to save that
for the pro version to
have that space gray,
the matte black.
It's gonna look good.
The train continues on its way
and now we're at the iPad pro.
And what is exciting,
the M1 is now coming to the iPad,
is that's going to be
so incredibly powerful
that it's going to be almost overkill
for most people that are going
to be needing this tablet.
But for people who are doing illustration,
video production, design,
real time, augmented reality,
whatever it is that you're doing
that is processor intensive,
like this iPad is more pro than ever.
I mean, I've seen the power,
just in my own experiences with this M1
and now that M1 going to the iMac
and now into the iPad,
it's pretty exciting.
They showed a demo of
something that's really cool
is this iPad is now 5G enabled.
So it's kind of gonna be
shifting the way I think
that a lot of us are
creating or consuming.
I also love the frame IO got to shout outs
because I'm a huge fan of frame IO.
I use that for all of my storage needs,
for transferring footage back and forth,
for sending videos to
clients for feedback.
And they've been working
on some really cool
camera to cloud transfer.
So throwing this new iPad in the mix,
it's going to be game-changing really.
So the iPad pro has a 50%
faster CPU, 40% faster graphics.
I also love that it has next
gen controller compatibility.
So all of the new next gen consoles
like the new Xbox and the PlayStation,
those controllers will
not work on the iPad.
It also has two X faster storage
and you can configure this thing
up to two terabytes of storage,
which is kind of mind blowing.
I mean, that's doubling the storage
over the previous version.
It also now has faster connectivity
because those USB-C ports are now going to
support Thunderbolt and USB four.
And it also supports the pro display XDR
at full 6k resolution.
What?!
They did a big update to
the true depth camera.
It's now ultra wide
and they have this feature
called center stage.
So when you're on one
of your FaceTime calls
or whatever call it is that you're doing,
I'm not sure if this will
carry over to zoom calls
or anything else,
it'll keep you in the center frame.
But here's the thing,
it looks like the camera
is only on the top still
because most of the time
when I'm using my iPad
it's in this sort of orientation.
So it would make more
sense to have that camera
in the center.
(indistinct)
Either way, I like the
center stage feature.
And I think that's going to definitely
be something that's utilized.
The display is something that
is also incredibly impressive.
They're calling this, the
liquid retina XDR display
and the full screen
brightness is a thousand
but at peak brightness
you can get 1600 nits,
which is pretty incredible.
It's crazy because the
starting price is very close.
If not exactly the same
as the previous version.
The iPad pro 11 inches starting at $799
and the iPad pro 12.9
inches starting at $1099.
And they also have a new
white magic keyboard cover
which I'm very, very excited about.
Really the main takeaway from this
is this is a 5G enabled iPad
which is kind of huge.
Especially if you're somebody
who is traveling a lot
or you need to be constantly
connected on your iPad.
Normally a lot of times
you could just get away
with using your phone as a hotspot
but the fact that everything is there,
color me impressed.
Well, guys, that was just
sort of a quick recap
of what happened at the Apple event today.
My sister and I are also
going to be doing a podcast
talking about some of the
things that we saw today
and discussing all of our
thoughts and reactions.
So be sure to check that
out, youtube.com/samebrain
or check out Same Brain on Apple podcasts
or anywhere that you listen to podcasts.
I look forward to seeing
you guys in my next video
and stay tuned for some
coverage on all of these things.
And I'll see you guys in the next video.
Subscribe, hit the bell, leave a comment.
Let me know your thoughts.
See you guys very, very soon.
Bye.
(outro music)